[Music]
to trigonometry on Francis Foster I'm
Constance and Kissin and this is a show
for you if you're bored of people
arguing on the internet over subjects
they know nothing about a trigonometry
we don't pretend to be the experts we
ask the experts
[Music]
here at our new studio our amazing
expert guest this week is Brendan
O'Neill who's the editor of spiked
online Brendan
welcome to trigonometry thank you very
much well it's great to have you here
you are known in addition to all your
writing of course particularly for the
free speech that you focused on so much
people call your free speech absolutist
yeah are you a free speech absolutist
yes what does that mean exactly it means
that I think freedom of speech is
absolute and there should be no
restrictions on it whatsoever no hate
speech laws I want to scrap all of those
no public order legislation that targets
speech no libel laws I think there
should be no restrictions whatsoever and
the best response to speech that is
wrong or dangerous or racist or horrible
is always more speech never censorship
never laws never putting someone in
prison so I'm a free speech absolutist
because I think freedom of speech should
be completely unfettered and so you
think for instance it should be
acceptable for somebody for instance in
any mom to go be able to go up on a
street corner for stand on a pallet and
say homosexual should be murdered for
instance yes yes and I actually have
defended Imams who have horrible views
about homosexuality or women or whatever
else it might be which a lot of free
speech activists that they actually run
out of steam when it comes to defending
extreme Islamists I definitely do I
think right and they suddenly think oh I
can't do that but I think obviously
there is such a thing as incitement to
violence and that's not a free speech
issue for the base from the point of
view that if you are inciting violence
you are conspiring in the commission of
a crime so that goes beyond freedom of
speech and then you are part of a
criminal conspiracy of some description
but I think even when it comes to
incitement to violence we have to be
really specific because that has become
a very misused term I was really struck
that the Metropolitan Police this week
or last week they were talking about
drill videos on YouTube drill is the
latest form of grind music lots of young
black kids listen to it in London and
elsewhere very violent music kind of
praises gangs and stabbing attacks and
guns and so on so it's and people are
very scared it's like the new gangster
raps yeah but in Britain instead of the
US and the police made this incredibly
interesting statement where they said
we're taking down hundreds of these
videos because we think they're
dangerous so I think that was an act of
police censorship and they said even if
there is no obvious act of violence that
has been incited by these videos we can
still say that these videos incite
violence I thought that was really
interesting because in Simon 2 violence
now means pretty much anything you want
it to mean it basically just means that
you really hate this form of speech
whether it's a drill video whether it's
Germaine Greer going to Cardiff
University and arguing that trans people
on real women that's also described as
incitement to violence
pretty much any form of speech can now
be described as an incitement to
violence so even there I think we have
to be very specific and I would like to
see evidence that the speech in question
directly contributed to an act of
violence before I would be willing to
sanction any form of punishment for that
speech what's interesting about that is
is that that has all that has always
been with us if you think about the
Jamey Bolger killings I mean 20 odd
years ago that was blamed on computer
video games if you think about the Shu
school students in Boulder Colorado they
blamed it on Marilyn Manson yeah do you
think you can ever attribute you know an
act of violence to a particular type of
thought oh yeah I think you can I think
mino' the guy at Mark David Chapman who
shot General John Lennon was inspired to
do side by JD Salinger's Catcher in the
Rye he really genuinely thought that
Catcher in the Rye was giving him a
message to kill John Lennon so you could
argue that Catcher in the Rye caused the
death of John Lennon or Charles Manson
and his crazy family were inspired to
kill all those people in Los Angeles by
the White Album I mean they really
genuinely believed it deep in their
heart that the White Album by the
Beatles contained all these messages
about race Wars and the piggies in the
capitalist society who needed to be
slaughtered and so on they really
believed that and of course you know
countless numbers of people have killed
because they read something in the Bible
or they
leave something in the Koran so it's
unquestionable that ideas can encourage
people to commit violent acts it's
unquestionable that some people will
look at a piece of art or read a book or
hear a song and think to themselves this
work of art is telling me to do
something really bad but if you were to
organize society on the basis that that
might happen then you are basically
creating a lunatic asylum in which all
of us are punished on the basis that one
or two crazy people might do something
stupid after reading Catcher in the Rye
or listening to the White Album and that
would be a deeply unpleasant Society
because there's no end of cultural
products or artistic things that could
be said to inspire violence or
hatefulness in one form or another so I
but my issue with media affects theory
which is this idea that video nasties
cause mass killings or video games made
the James Bulger murder happen or in the
modern version because the left that
effects theory used to be very prominent
on the right
among kind of old Christian women and
Mary Whitehouse types and very
conservative stiff people now it's kind
of shifted to the left and it's very
much more from the left now that argues
about media effects theory and will say
that lads mags if they're in shop on
shop shelves will cause men to become
rapacious and anti women or violence
against women in films will cause men to
commit violence against women in real
life so the left has utterly embraced
the media effects Theory my problem with
the media effects theory is that it
presents all people as almost like
animals who just look at something and
then think I must act on that and that
is a very demeaning view of the vast
majority of human beings who actually
are perfectly capable of thinking for
themselves and perfectly capable of
making a decision about what they should
do with their lives so I would be very
wary of any justification of censorship
that was made on the basis that we
basically are monkey-see monkey-do and
that we see something or hear something
and then immediately feel that we have
to commit violent
on the back of it well what about the
Frances specific example by the man
right who's out on the street saying
homosexuals must be stoned to death for
example is that an assignment of
violence not necessarily there's an exam
actual example of this which was I got
into a debate with Peter Tatchell about
we had him on the show a couple weeks
right I go in and I agree with him on
many things but one thing that we
disagreed on very much about 10 or 15
years ago was dancehall music from
Jamaica which has homophobic lyrics and
it includes things like it says things
like throw the gays onto the fire and
things like that you know so quite
violent imagery and Brighton I think it
was in Brighton some clubs started to
ban this music and then people were
calling for a ban across Britain and
then it shouldn't be played in public
that you should even ban the sale of it
potentially and Peter Tatchell although
he's generally quite good on the freedom
of speech question was on on the side of
banning this music precisely because he
said it's incitement to violence and I
was against that on the basis that to my
mind that wasn't a specific enough
example of incitement to violence I
think if you're in a club at 2:00
o'clock in the morning and you're
dancing and you're drunk and there's a
song on the speaker over there and
probably the most of the lyrics are
actually quite unintelligible because
it's very loud and the music's thumping
and you hear someone say throw gays onto
the fire or whatever the lyric was if
you then go out and do something like
that you have completely and utterly
made a free choice you've used your free
will you have decided to do this thing
this terrible thing and to hold the
music responsible for that I think is
ridiculous and a complete cop-out and
actually calls into question the very
notion of free will well in the music I
would totally agree with you
but what about their mom on the street
literally saying these people should be
killed it did well even there the
question comes back to how he's saying
it the context in which he's saying it
and whether he's saying about specific
individuals if he was on a street corner
and he was pointing at a gay couple and
saying these people need to be killed
that's not freedom of speech that is an
incitement to violence particularly if
there was an atmosphere around him
there were other radical Muslims
listening to him and getting heated up
and he pointed at someone specific and
said they deserve to die because they're
gay that's not a free speech issue that
is what I would call incitement to
violence the American Civil Liberties
Union which is infinitely better on the
question of freedom of speech than any
organisation in Britain has a very clear
definition of incitement of violence
which is speech where there is you
should know as a reasonable human being
that your there is a clear and present
possibility that your words will cause
violence so if there and I generally
accept that definition of incitement to
violence if that Imam was pointing at a
specific people and there was a mob
around him and they were getting angry
and being homophobic and everything else
and he instructed them to do something
and they did it he could be held
responsible alongside them
for what happened but if he's on a
soapbox saying homosexuality is sinful
and homosexuality should be put to death
that's different that's the expression
of a repugnant religious conviction as
opposed to direct core as opposed to a
direct incitement of specific people to
attack specific people yeah and there is
nothing that's important to hold up that
distinction it's because people have
been arrested in Britain for saying
homophobic things in public a Christian
preacher was arrested two or three years
ago because he was on a soapbox in
public he didn't incite violence but he
said homosexuality is repugnant and he
quoted from the Book of Revelations and
various other things and some young gay
couple walking paths took offence and
phoned the police and he was arrested
and he was put in a prison cell for 19
hours and then eventually the charges
against him were dropped the police
decided in their infinite wisdom that he
hadn't crossed the line into committing
a crime but he was the image cell for 19
hours I find it terrifying in Britain in
the 21st century you can be put into a
jail cell for 19 hours effectively from
for reading from the Book of Revelations
in public I think that's the kind of
tyrannical development that we should be
more concerned about rather than the
possibility that an imam will get up in
public and say those things which
actually strikes me as increasingly
unlikely because not least because a few
years ago when radical Muslims marched
in public with placard saying behead
critics of Islam or whatever behead the
blasphemers a lot of them were arrested
and punished which I have a problem with
but that is what happened and subsequent
to that there have been fewer of those
violent violently imaged protests by
radical so we've talked about some of
the things of where we are in Britain
with free speech and also where you'd
like to be wait how you see the world
ideally where are we now what's the
reality of the free speech issue in
Britain today it's really in a bad state
we have we don't have freedom of speech
in Britain now when you say that to
people they say oh but I can generally
say whatever I want yeah you can but not
everyone else can and freedom of speech
by its definition either extends to
everyone or extends to no-one
so who's unable to speak now various
people have been arrested for things
that they said or questioned by the
police for jokes that they made there's
the example of Camden killer who was
arrested and charged with grossly
offensive crime for getting his
girlfriend's pub to do a Nazi salute
which is I tell that story in Brazil at
a conference in Brazil a few weeks ago
and they were they couldn't believe this
was happening and that's a country not
long out of actual dictatorship
countdown kilo is one example there have
been other examples a couple of weeks
ago no one wants to talk about this
because it is deeply controversial a man
was arrested and charged with a crime
for making an anti-jewish speech in a
Jewish area of London Golders Green or
Stanford Hill which one clearly an
anti-semite the Allison Chad loss was
last week she's a notorious Holocaust
denier vile vile despicable woman who
was a few years ago prevented from
performing at Edinburgh because her
songs were included references to the
Holocaust being a sham and so on she was
found guilty last week a few a few days
ago off being grossly offensive online
because she posted two songs on YouTube
in which she denied the Holocaust and
that's a really significant case
because Britain has always refused to
criminalize Holocaust denial which i
think is the right thing to do we should
absolutely challenge Holocaust denial
we should ridicule it we should combat
it with all the army of facts that
demonstrate what happened in Europe in
the 1930s and 40s but we shouldn't
criminalize it so because she couldn't
be found guilty of Holocaust no because
that's not a crime in Britain instead
she was found guilty being grossly
offensive under the 2003 Communications
Act which basically means that this is
an incredibly section one to seven of
this Act which says that if you post or
say something grossly offensive online
you could be taken to court I think that
section one to seven is a despicable
menace to freedom of speech and has been
used in an incredibly promiscuous
fashion to punish all sorts of people
including count Acula and others who who
simply say things that some people find
unpalatable or offensive or nauseating
or wrong so we so what's the state of
free speech in Britain the state of free
speech in Britain is that we have actual
laws that prevent you from saying
certain things we have actual people
being arrested and fined for having said
things that they believed to be true or
having made jokes that people that
people find offensive and we have the
police knocking on people's doors and
telling them off for things that they
said on Twitter this actually happened
one example is the the young guy in
yuccas I think he made a joke about the
Glasgow lorry disaster and Christmas a
couple of years ago a lorry spun out of
control and killed six people in Glasgow
on a High Street someone made a joke on
Twitter which I won't repeat because it
was really actually was a horrible joke
the police went to his house and told
him to stop saying these things online
so free speech is in a really poor way
and people I think need to realise that
they need to realize fundamentally that
if we don't have freedom of speech for
all these people who we might consider
to be on the outskirts of acceptable
thinking then we don't have freedom of
speech we have licensed speech we have
speech we have a situation where you are
allowed to say things so long as you
don't offend someone in a position of
authority that's not freedom of speech
that's licensed speech we're all now
basically speaking on license and if we
cross a line we could actually go to
court but what's wrong with having
licensed speech I mean I'll be honest
for you I don't want to hear someone
who'd deny in the whole of course cuz
it's nonsense I don't want to hear
people having people having the right to
talk about beheading people who don't
who are unbelievers or apostates what's
wrong with that it's wrong for two
reasons firstly it's wrong because
however much you don't want to hear
these things and I don't want to hear
them either as it happens
some people believe them and I think
it's always wrong to prevent people from
saying what they believe it's always
important to remember that one man's
hate speeches and other man's deeply
held moral conviction some people really
believe as a deeply held moral
conviction that the Holocaust didn't
happen I think they're barmy I think
they are all racist I think Holocaust
now is always driven by racism I think
they are they twist facts or they make
facts up I think they're crazy I think
they're deluded but they they really
believe that they build their whole
lives around this moral conviction or to
give a more mainstream example there are
some people smaller numbers than in the
past but there are some people who think
that gay sex is sinful and disgusting
and if you do it you will literally burn
in hell they genuinely believe that and
if you punish people for what they
genuinely believe then you have entered
into a an actual Orwellian society so
because who's to tell when the
definition of an unacceptable belief
won't be expanded and won't at some
point include what you believe or what I
believe or any of us believe so that's
the first problem you should never stop
people from saying what they think to be
true even if you know that it's not true
and then the second reason that we
should let them say these things is
because the rest of us the audience the
ordinary people the public needs to have
the right to hear this stuff so that we
can decide for ourselves whether it's
good or bad whether it's right or wrong
and how we might confront it I think one
of the worst problems with censorship is
that it infantilizes the public it
treats us as these children who have to
have our ears and eyes covered by
gracious people in
positions of authority so that we never
hear things that they've decided on our
behalf are wrong or incorrect or
offensive
so censorship has this incredibly
corrosive infantilizing impact across
society where everyone is reduced to the
level of a child and as a consequence
your moral and mental muscles get weaker
and weaker because they're never called
in to use you never have to use them to
decide for yourself to use your moral
judgment and decide okay that idea is
[ __ ] and I know this because I've
thought about it I've talked to people
about it I've read about it and I've
investigated it John Stuart Mill makes
this point in on Liberty which is
probably the best thing ever written
about freedom of speech he makes the
point that if you are prevented from
using your moral muscles if you are
prevented from hearing everything and
making a judgment between these
different things you hear then you are
basically not a human you're an ape and
you're following orders
and you're being instructed on how to
govern your way through life so I would
say censorship is bad for two reasons
firstly because it stops people from
saying things that they think are true
and good and interesting even if most
people think they're not and even worse
it reduces the public to the level of
infants or or animals who have to be
protected from things they couldn't
possibly understand so it has an
incredibly corrosive impact on public
life itself no I was actually gonna move
on from that actually just it's
interesting for me because I agree with
you to a large extent not fully but to a
large extent on the principle around
freedom of speech but the difficulty and
Francis and I've talked with various
guests about this the difficulty that we
have is free speech has become so
associated with right-wing policies with
all right now that when you talk about
the reason that we have a problem of
free speech in this country is that a
Holocaust denier couldn't go into
Golders Green and do an anti Holocaust
denial speech or whatever right I kind
of I struggle to go yeah that's that's
I'm gonna you know
I struggle you don't say that prove it
my no but you know what I mean like in
principle I totally agree with you but
the practical reality is that yeah the
people who are now being bandied about
as these champions of free speech
horrible people yes with whom none of us
would want to have anything to do with I
completely kind of fighting and I get it
I get that the idea of free speech as
you fight for free speech for the person
you despise because anything else isn't
free speech but it's so difficult I
think particularly in the current
climate to go yeah well these Holocaust
deniers they should be should be free to
speak yeah but I think you're right you
have to defend scum in order to defend
freedom for everyone and that's always
been the way freedom of speech has
worked and the way I see it when I
defend freedom of speech for like the
the Holika the singing Holocaust denier
who is recently convicted I see myself
is not defending her but defending us
ordinary people because what I'm saying
is I trust people to be able to hear
these things and to know that they're
wrong I trust people to be able to use
their mental faculties and come to a
good sensible citizen decision what the
state is saying and what all these kind
of supposedly left-wing demanders of
censorship are saying is they don't
trust us they don't trust people they
think we're idiots they think we're
stupid they think we're children and
they must look after us that's the
dynamic that has to be challenged it's
not as if I'm on a street corner
saying I really desperately want to hear
this stupid woman's Holocaust denying
songs has it happens I have watch them
and they're dreadful and she's an idea
and everything else and they're not even
catchy so it's not as if I'm out there
because I'm so desperate to hear this
stuff but I am incredibly keen to defend
the idea that the great thing about
freedom of speech is that it creates a
situation where ordinary people are
trusted to make decisions for themselves
that's the main thing about it and that
means you have to defend awful people
HL Mencken the great American journalist
made this point he said you have to
defend scoundrels because laws of
censorship and laws of authoritarianism
always target scoundrels first and if
you let them fall by the wayside it
could be you next Thomas Paine made this
argument a great Thomas Paine
the English radical probably my one hero
in history made the point that if you
don't defend freedom for your enemy then
you set in motion a precedent that will
one day come and bite you on the ass
didn't say that he's better English and
that still stands that's still true that
is still true and as an example in the
1980's the 1990s and the 2000s the left
in Britain having lost the plot and
given up on freedom to such a great then
would often argue for far right marches
to be banned and for far-right protests
to be banned and the government because
the government loves banning things said
fine we'll do it lo and behold there
were some occasions when left-wing had
to be said what okay and now we want to
hold an anti race an anti-fascist March
to show that we are really serious about
this and the government said oh no we
think that will be disruptive as well
know now we've we sorted out the
situation for you so go home and they
banned those demonstrations as well if
you demand if you call for people to be
censored you haven't got a leg to stand
on when someone comes to censor you you
haven't got a leg to stand on and that's
what these leftist censors don't
understand the reason you have to defend
free speech for fascists and racist and
homophobes and Islamists and everyone
else is because you have to defend
freedom of speech for yourself and
that's the thing they always forget I
mean it's absolutely so as many times on
the podcast we're saying it's
fascinating but you know what it was I
would disagree with you and I would burn
that woman's comedy songs because I hate
[ __ ] comedy and I've listened to too
much of it immediately
and I was up to you half the comedy so
oh yeah babe in the NGO like
and I like the fact that you criticize
he said it was horrible it was racist
and the worst thing not even can I find
it very very interesting your point
about in particular identity politics
would you be able to talk about identity
politics in particular what identity
politics means to you identity politics
means to me it really means an
abandonment of the ideals of
universalism and the idea that what we
share in common is more important than
what what differentiates us and this is
an idea as old as time I mean it most
clearly expressed of course by Martin
Luther King and his dream of a future in
which people would be judged according
to their character rather than the color
of their skin that I think is a pretty
good progressive view of how we should
live but the left recently the foal EFT
the phony left of the [ __ ] left or
wherever we want to refer to as has
completely abandoned the idea of
universalism or the idea that human
beings have much in common despite their
different backgrounds despite their
different skin colors despite their
different genders and has gone down the
road of this separatist divisive racial
politics of identity and now what we
have is a left that thinks hyper
racially all the time about everything
you know they go and watch a movie and
then they go home and write a tumblr
post about how many black people were in
it or how much speaking time the black
woman had or they will stand up on
campus and say as a black lesbian or as
a Muslim homosexual or as a or as a
white man and then they always make a
very apologetic statement about their
privileged life so you have this bizarre
situation where the left we're used to
be at the forefront of challenging the
whole idea of race basically saying
racist nonsense it's a made-up category
which doesn't actually define how human
beings exist or or what we're like
that's what the left always said they
said it was made up and we should stop
using it too now to a situation where
the left embraces the politics of racial
difference in fact and the politics of
sexual difference and war
often and defines everyone and every
aspect of life according to race
background cultural inherited traits and
so on so I find that identity politics I
find it to be incredibly divisive and
poisonous and destructive and I think
the left's embrace of it really speaks
to the left's abandonment of some of its
good traditional ideals primarily that
to be universal and to see the universal
similarities and human beings is a good
idea why do you say it's the left
because I recognize what you're talking
about on the left but I think
fundamentally it's happening on the
right as well yeah and that's actually
to meet a much bigger concern is the
adoption of identity politics on the
right because we've seen where that
leads before and if there's one group of
people that that you worry about banding
together on the basis of identities
white men well I think you're right I
think in fact identity politics in its
original form going back a couple of
hundred years it comes from the right in
fact identity politics could be seen
very much as a kind of right-wing
reactionary response to the
Enlightenment so you have the enlighten
you have this great progressive leap
forward everyone saying let's use our
moral reason let's have freedom of
speech let's let's give this idea ago
that ordinary people can run their lives
without having priests and kings
breathing down their necks all the time
wonderful step forward for human thought
and human society and the right or
reactionary elements or romantic
elements as they sometimes refer to
themselves responded to that by
basically saying ah but human beings are
very different so the enlightenment
philosophers often talked about man you
know the a little bit sexist they didn't
talk about men and women but they talked
about man this idea of universal man and
there was one famous French reactionary
Joseph de Maistre who responded to that
by saying what is man all I see is
Italian men and French men and white men
and black men so that's a very early
expression of identity politics in
response to a progressive enlightened
view of human beings as being quite
universal and so on so it comes from the
right to begin with tragically I think
it's really is an epoch
tragedy the left then starts to adopt it
really from the mid 20th century onwards
and then really in a pronounced way from
the 1980s onwards and as you say the
right never really gave it up as it
happens they've always been into
identity they've always thought there
are significant differences between
races and so on and now the right is
embracing it again yeah through the
alt-right and through white nationalism
and other things like that I see that
very much as a response to the Institute
institutionalization of identity
politics by certain elements on the left
and by the political class itself so I
think if you create a situation where
you are constantly saying to people
you're a white man you're a white man
you're a white man you can't say that
you're a white man you shouldn't be here
you're a white man you shouldn't be
speaking over this woman because you're
a white man eventually those white men
are going to turn around and say okay
I'm a white man and that's how you're
defining me and everything I do and
everything I believe so maybe that's how
I should define myself and everything I
do and everything I believe so I think
this new tragic sad possibly dangerous
movement of white men which I still
think is quite a minority and I think it
gets slightly blown out of proportion I
do see that as a response to this new
identity politics and this encouragement
it's incitement of people to constantly
define themselves by their skin color
and their sex lo and behold you have a
new movement of white men saying ok
that's all we are we're white men and
we're going to stick together we're
going to have white pride so I think
that's a new manifestation of the old
right-wing identity politics and it's
been encouraged and infused and shaped I
think by left-wing identity politics
incredibly powerful movement so we're
talking about identity and whiteness and
kind of skin color and all these things
here we are three white men or
technically I mean Francis mother's from
Venezuela so he's technically okay I'm
from Russia I have quite dark skin but
nominally we're still three white well
I'm Irish and we're the blacks of Europe
right okay so none of us none of us here
is white but actually I I when we had
Andrew Dolan and I told him that when I
was growing up in Russia if someone
wanted to be rude to me on the street
which happened every now and again they
would say to me you're black go home
because people who have dark skin like
me in Russia they are the discriminate
against minority but anyway in this
country where white right yeah three of
us talking about race in a room there's
got to be a hate crime in themselves
yeah you you just wrote a color recently
caught a column about how white guilt is
essentially become a perverse way of
signaling your virtue and it's becoming
almost white pride away could you yeah
sounds very counterintuitive what do you
mean by that
yeah it's all these people who are
constantly checking their white
privilege and you know they go online
they go on Twitter they go on Facebook
or they write articles and they say I'm
white I have to recognize that I'm a
very privileged person and I shouldn't
speak over black people I shouldn't
speak over women and so on and I've been
watching this go on for a few years now
and I was thinking it's really strange
because it's it looks shameful you know
they're very ashamed of being white
they're very ashamed of what they call
white history and colonialism and Empire
and everything else so they expressed
this great shame but they do it in such
a showy narcissistic ostentatious way
look at me I'm so ashamed and what you
realize is that actually there's a real
boastfulness to this checking of your
white privilege and they're really
making a public display of it so I think
what's going on here is that this
expression of white shame or this
expression of white guilt has really
become a new form of white pride because
in essence what they're saying is we are
good white people we're very socially
and politically aware we're switched on
we're sensitive to the crimes of history
we're sensitive to the needs and
interests of black people we're good
whites
not like those otherwise the uneducated
ones the uncouth ones the ones who
didn't go to Oxford University the ones
who don't read the Guardian the ones who
don't use Twitter they're the bad whites
so what you see is they're creating
almost this new white nationalism
ironically where they are demonstrating
their decent whiteness in contrast
largely to bad white people so it's a
very racially driven form of narcissism
I think this checking of your white
privilege it's also so not only does it
do mean bad whites
I think implicitly the means bad words
it also do means black people because
it's driven by this idea that black
people are quite fragile and therefore
there are certain things you shouldn't
say in their presence or there are
certain things that we maybe shouldn't
publish or there are certain speakers we
shouldn't invite to campus because black
people would disappear into a crisis of
self-esteem which i think is also a very
racially driven denigrated view of black
people so i think this idea that
whiteness is this all-powerful thing and
it can even induce trauma in people
because you know whiteness is this
powerful force actually what that says
is that white people are very strong and
black people who might crumble if you
say something racist or my crumble if
you invite Tommy Robinson to your campus
are very weak so it actually
rehabilitates is politically correct
white guilt which is now incredibly
fashionable actually recreates the idea
that whites are the adults with great
power to cause distress and blacks are
the children who might sometimes need
censorship and other things to protect
them from offensive ideas I find it
really repugnant and that's one of the
examples of how identity politics we
when you think
Hyper racially all the time you end up
rehabilitating racial stereotypes in
this case that whites are all powerful
and blacks are weak and that's where
this identity politics is taking us it's
taking us down a very dark alley towards
the old racist politics that so many of
us have spent a lot of time trying to
escape and or to defeat so what do you
make of the concept of white privilege
in general I think it's [ __ ] I think
it's it expresses a very infantile way
of understanding society and the dynam
in society do I think there's racism of
course by also I think racism is far
rarer now than it was in the past I
think it's become this minority pursuit
among pockets of people whereas in the
past and even I'm old enough to remember
this it was a fairly dominant ideology
in Western societies
I think that's faded away and that's all
to the good but racism yes racism still
exists but whatever it is isn't about
racism sorry to interrupt it's not about
racism it's the idea that you and I
walking down the street will be treated
differently to to black people walking
down the street by other people by shop
assistants by the police by whatever
that's the idea yeah but that's not
necessarily true but the reason I think
it's a very narrow way to understand
societies because I think you're far
greater influence on people's fortunes
is class and that's how I think is a far
better way to understand society so the
idea that you know people say privileged
white men privileged white this
privileged white that the vast majority
of white people don't have don't enjoy
any form of privilege and are actually
quite poor or working-class the majority
of them and the idea of white privilege
is actually one that comes from a very
privileged strata of society which is
academia and professors and all these
kind of young people brought up in a
very middle-class homes to go off to
university and come up with these
theories about white privilege so it's
this very bizarre twisted ridiculous
idea that you know these like those
black kids are Oxford who are the all
there on Rhodes Scholarships
so the they come from incredibly
privileged backgrounds and they're on
Rhodes Scholarships at Oxford the finest
university in the world and they spend
the whole time going on about how
privileged white people are what
including the the Polish white man who
who built the extension to your house or
I don't know the the Turkish white man
who cleans your toilet what are we
talking about here there's a real
unwillingness to understand the
complexities of modern society and the
fact that in my view class remains the
deciding factor as to your
fortunes and where you going and how
successful you can be you know this has
really brought home by there's a trans
there's a black trans woman called Munro
Bergdorf and she gave an into to the
guardian recently because she got in
trouble because she said all white
people are racist and she gave an
interview to the Guardian and she was
explaining her concept of white
privilege and she said even a homeless
white man has privilege and the
justification she gave was that in
comparison with a homeless black man
he's got more chance of getting out and
she didn't provide any statistics for
that or anything like that but the point
is she came she comes from an incredibly
privileged background her mother was
very successful in business she had a
lovely upbringing she now has a very
lovely life and she is telling the man
who lives under a bridge and is addicted
to heroin and might starve to death any
moment now that he enjoys privilege
that's how screwed up identity politics
has become and I think identity politics
increasingly looks like the revenge of
the elite and and it's a way for them to
to fly in the face of all the evidence
and to argue that they are the victims
they are the great victims of life
because you know the white man who's
living in a skip has more privileged
than they do it's utterly surreal I
don't think it's sustainable and I think
it's a very again it's very poisonous
argument because it divides society
along racial lines when in fact I think
the key divide in society is still um on
matters of wealth and class that's very
very interesting how you pointed that
out to me I think that identity politics
is actually a great one of the greatest
dangers to freedom of speech in that
people are willing to engage in debate
because what people now do is they don't
let you put forward that argument but I
know there's a counter-argument to that
which would just be well as a white man
yeah you're not entitled to those views
or opinions simply because you've never
experienced a struggle in inverted
commas and therefore completely
denigrating your argument instead of
actually engaging with the argument and
putting forward a counter counter point
of view which is entirely reasonable
it's simply to attack the person
speaking and the moment you do that I've
I think they're all semblance of
discussion and freedom of speech it just
goes out
is dead yeah it's terrible because
people's ideas and views are judged on
the basis of their skin color and all
their genitals or whatever it might be
rather than on what they're actually
saying which cap runs counter to every
democratic liberal ideal which is that
you should hear people out have the
discussion have an open discussion and
then work out as a society what's good
and what's bad and where we should go
and so on so it runs I completely agree
is completely destructive of freedom of
speech and open debate and what it does
it really causes people to climb up so
people feel that there are certain
things I shouldn't say in public or and
lots of when I go to campuses and so on
there's often white men who just saw
really I'm sure about whether they
should say something in this meeting
well they should just sit there and it
was really brought home there was some
demonstration in the US a year or so ago
and there was this white man on it
holding up a placard saying I was going
to write a placard but I thought it was
that we've heard enough from white men
so I won't and that was his back which
is which I thought well anything else
it's still a [ __ ] black yellow
placard but it was a very good it was a
very good example of how narcissistic
privilege is because he was really
saying I'm I'm I'm the best white person
in the world that's what he was really
saying but it's that thing of people
closed down and clam up they're not sure
what they can say and so it gives rise
to one of the great scourge ha's of our
time I think which is self-censorship
and that uncertainty and that well can I
say this I've got white skin I was born
male am I allowed to say this or should
I not say and you think what a
destructive situation that is for us to
find ourselves in I think it also the
other side of it it's not only that it
is destructive or freedom of speech it
also really whips up this victim
politics because you have this
competitive victimhood now where
everyone is trying to demonstrate that
they are greater victim than someone
else because being a victim is now the
way in which you win social praise even
in some cases government funding you
know that's the basis on which lots of
community groups win government funding
is through saying we have all these
various problems it's the way in which
you win moral authority through being a
victim whereas in the past you might
have won more authority by demonstrating
your autonomy and your
adulthood and the fact that you were
capable of governing your own life now
in a complete flip reversal you win
moral authority in 21st century Britain
by showing your wounds I'm a victim I've
had a really crap life so what that does
it encourages people to constantly
exaggerate and blow out proportion of
the problems they faced you know and so
I think there's a lot of myth making
among some of these identitarian about
how awful their lives have been I don't
buy it for a minute because they're
encouraged to do that because they need
that victim Authority and also gives
rise to this incredibly divisive
competition between different groups
well we're bigger victims than you and
it has this fragmentary process even
within identity groups or even within
for example trans the trans community as
it's called even there people will say
oh but you're a white trans person I'm a
black trans person and we have it worse
than you or in the gay community people
will say but I'm Muslim in gay
that's far harder than some way of
appear that one's ever had to face so
this kind of complete breaking apart
even off the identity groups themselves
so that you end up with all these tiny
sectarian bloc's who just are constantly
fighting for that moral high-ground of
victimhood so they can say well I'm the
chief victim therefore I deserve the
money and I deserved a newspaper column
and I deserve the sympathy so that's
really bad and and I think it's added
really destructive impact on the new
generation in particular because I go to
campuses and speak and I constantly meet
these young people who have really
plummy posh voices and you can tell they
had really nice upbringing and they want
to convince you that they suffer from
structural oppression that they are they
face abuse and hardship every day of
their life that they are the most
downtrodden community in living memory
and you just want to shake them and say
that's not true but of course what you
really should do as someone who cares
about the future of society check your
priveledge and try and work out why
they're saying this why are they saying
these things which are patently untrue
and the reason they're saying them is
because identity politics encourages you
to see yourself as weak and pathetic
whereas left-wing politics in particular
but also right-wing liberal politics
used to encourage you to see yourself as
confident and
capable and that shift is really worried
now how did we get to this age of
victimhood because it seems to be
everywhere
yes like what you're talking about I
think a lot of people who are not
interested in identity politics are all
this political conversations I think a
lot of people I was speaking to someone
earlier today who isn't into at all but
this general purveying sense that now
being a victim is better than not being
a victim somehow that instead of driving
instead of trying to achieve things
instead of trying to make the best of
your lot in life instead of overcoming
challenges your job in life is to
identify and broadcast to the world the
challenges that you face how how did we
get here I was gonna say you don't think
it's just simply because it's easier
just to go yeah my life is hard then
going faces challenges I've got a
workout I've got a look at myself I've
got to improve I'm gonna have to take
knock backs yeah I think that there's an
element where it's easier but but then
the flip side of that is that it also
makes were shallower leymah life and and
I think if you when people embrace that
victim script I think sometimes they
actually become quite depressed or down
because they realize that their life is
quite hollow because all they're doing
concern is is exaggerating every problem
they face and then they go out there
with this victim and 10i on always
switched up to high so that you know the
man who brushes past them on the tube
that's an example of patriarchy
patriarchy or misogyny or the person who
says to them to a black woman oh I love
your hair where did you get it done
that's a microaggression which is
evidence of the continued existence of
racism so they they can't even engage in
everyday conversation I thought the
roads must fall campaign in Oxford where
they want to take down this statue of
Cecil Rhodes who is a old colonialist
was a good example of this because they
the students who want to tear that down
described it as an environmental micro
aggression so they even see inanimate
objects statues buildings as things that
are attacking them so I think when you
have this victim identity you perceive
yourself as being constantly under
attack when you're not at all but
everything every conversation starter
every statue on the street corner
every person who just asks you a
perfectly innocent question is evidence
of your victimhood and and and
consequently evidence of everyone else's
horribleness so you go through life with
a very misanthropic view of society I
think so I think it does make things
easier but it makes for a much shallower
existence as to where it came from I
think you know I get attacked for left
bashing but I do think the left bears a
lot of responsibility for this and I do
think that the left turn you know really
around the 1960s and then it picks up
hugely in the 1980s you have this shift
from a left that was interested in jobs
and people having enough money and
people having a nice life and people
being going through life confident and
capable and going on strike and making
demands and when that was your view of
the world people had to be strong I had
to be strong because every now and then
they would have to make a really firm
demand for a better pay and conditions
and a better form of existence so the
left then would would tend to encourage
people you know you're a strong person
you can do this we can do this together
then sometimes around the 1960s and the
1970s the left shifts from those
economic questions to cultural questions
shifts from discussing jobs and wages
and the right to live in a nice house
and all those practical tangible things
towards talking about issues of identity
and and minority life and women's issues
as well although I do think women's
issues are important there is this very
palpable shift from the left in the
left's focus and I think bit by bit that
gives rise to a situation where the left
becomes less and less likely to say
you're strong you can do this you're a
capable person and more likely to say
maybe you can't do this
maybe you're a victim maybe we need to
set up a new community group to look
after people like you maybe we need to
get the millions in funding from the
government in order to do that and and
slowly over time you have a left which
is very influential in local councils
very influential in local politics and
then eventually very influential in
national politics on the basis that
many people in society are vulnerable as
their favorite word well they call them
the vulnerable and it falls to them to
help look after these people so I think
that's a really important dynamic in
giving rise to a situation where people
are actively encouraged to advertise
their weaknesses rather than encouraged
to believe in their strengths and that's
the real problem
the thing I find very very difficult was
when people here talked about oppression
my mother is from Venezuela you probably
know a lot about Venezuela you know it's
a totalitarian regime essentially if you
criticize the government at one o'clock
in the morning you will get a knock on
the door and you will literally
disappear and then when people here talk
about how they're oppressed I just yeah
it makes me angry it's it's it's yeah I
feel the same it's it's complete
nonsense my parents are from the West of
Ireland and they grew up in pretty awful
situation and that's why they moved to
London because they couldn't work there
they wouldn't have really got on in
Ireland very well at all so they moved
to London and then they moved into a
one-bedroom flat and very quickly he had
five children so there were seven people
in a one-bedroom flat a council flat and
then eventually moved into a council
house and so on and that was very
difficult for my parents I was a really
that was is what I would describe as a
hard life a tough life so when I hear
people now who are at Oxford and they
sound like they've been a elocution
lessons for half their life and they
obviously have never worked a day in
their life never mind struggled trying
to convince me that they suffer from
oppression
it makes me quite angry and I think
they're talking nonsense but I think
that's and but trying to work out why
they do that and trying to develop a
counter-argument that is better than
just shaking them by the scruff of their
neck that's one of the challenges I
think people face now if we want to
overturn this kind of politics but I
think it's like you know they're always
chasing that dream of having experienced
depression and and
it's the reverse it's like the reverse
of the American dream yeah you know and
you would want to chase the dream of
having a house and a job and being a
kind of capable member of your community
now you almost do the opposite so it's
tragedy well how much of it is it's
interesting that you frame it like that
I never heard a friend lleva it's a very
accurate observation I think that's a
reverse of the American dream how much
of it is it because essentially we in
the West you know Francis from Venezuela
I am from Russia as I said we in the
West we've achieved to a very
significant extent what you might refer
to as an American dream where wealthy
were prosperous we're relatively free
we're relatively safe we're secure
there's a certain kind of stability and
predictability to our lives we don't
face the kind of daily challenges that
most of the other 7 billion people on
the planet do face you know these issues
are not an issue in Russia they're not
an issue I'd imagine in Venice relative
to anywhere near the same extent
identity apologies no I think people
with 18 yeah yeah widows widows why
don't ya well that's my point right so
how much of it is it essentially we've
solved all our basic problems so now we
need some other problems to solve
because that's how yeah I used to think
that about climate change I'm a climate
change skeptic not a climate change
denier it's very important difference
there I do think it's happening and I do
think humankind bears some
responsibility but I used to think
similarly about climate change which I
used to think that the West had it
pretty good for the most part poverty
still poor people still unemployment and
all those things that need to be
resolved but generally pretty good and
we needed a new focus for all our angst
and fury and concerns and I always
thought that climate change activism
which seems to fizzle out a little bit
at least recently which I find really
interesting climate change activism I
thought was a very middle class largely
middle-class hand-wringing campaign
where I thought was exactly that it was
a way in which they could find something
in an otherwise pretty nice existence
that they could say oh my god it's the
end of the world we have to do something
about this whereas in the third world
they don't worry about crime
change because they still don't have
roads and they still don't have
hospitals and they still don't have
schools and they still don't have
factories and they they want those
things so I think there's an element of
that is I think there's an element where
we've reached a certain level in Western
society of comfort and general freedom
or thereabout all that is collapsing
fast and people are looking for another
way to to gain meaning in their lives
but the great complex question I think
is why they now seek meaning through
victimhood rather than through other
things like autonomy or the pursuit of I
don't know hobbies and interests or the
creation of new forms new ways of living
or new forms of society there's so many
or putting your energies into recreating
the space race or developing nuclear
technology there are so many positive
things that even a society that's
reached a pretty good level of wealth
and openness could still pursue but
instead we kind of poopoo all that stuff
is really dangerous and damaging and
just focus on Stara our own navels and
our own victimhood so I'm interested in
as to why the question of why when
society reaches this level it goes it's
now gone down this incredibly negative
route but I think the key thing about
victim politics I think is that it it
works best for the people who actually
aren't victims of life like middle-class
people
academics professors well-off students
and so on but it doesn't work for people
who actually are victims of life like
the poor and people looking for a job
and people struggling to make ends meet
because they still have to be strong
because otherwise they won't get to the
end of the week without getting hungry
so that's the real interesting split in
victim politics which is I always think
that the people who played the victim
card most must have a really nice life
because if you are living on the streets
or in a small house and you've got five
mouths to feed and you're gonna run out
of work in a few weeks time and you need
to find more work you can't go around
saying oh woe is me my life so hard my
my great-grandfather was enslaved you
haven't got time for all that stuff you
have to focus and you have to have
self-drive and you
have to magic up all your moral autonomy
and self-confidence and capability in
order to continue living so that I think
is very interesting where I think victim
politics is most pronounced among those
who've had a very cushioned existence
whereas I think it is a very unusual
politics among those who haven't had a
cushioned existence and therefore still
need to demonstrate their moral
independence if they're going to get
through life in in good shape moving on
now you I was reading an article that
spiked magazine did it and it was a very
very interesting attack on the left over
grenfell and the way that they have used
politicized Grenfell and used it as a
way to attack right-wing politics and to
and in particular to resume and her
government and how in many ways immoral
days would you like to expand on that a
little bit yeah I think what the left is
done with gravel is really obnoxious
well Brendon actually before you get
into that sorry why don't you tell us a
little bit about grandpa for
international viewers you might not know
what were talking about so grandpa was
this unspeakable disaster that happened
in London about a year ago in which a
block of flats caught fire and 71 people
killed in Kensington and Chelsea so
really nice part of London but this was
a very working-class or immigrant or
lower-class block and it caught fire
very quickly and within three hours or
so 71 people had been killed so a really
shocking incident in British history a
black mark against this nation I would
say so a lot of questions need to be
asked and answered and there's currently
an inquiry looking into why it happened
and what went wrong and and what we can
do in the future to prevent anything
like this from happening again
what happened with the left is that
almost as soon as the fire happened they
were using it exploiting it I would say
to make political points about things
like neoliberalism
and capitalism and the Tories and all
these things they don't like and
creating this very childish I think
narrative which said that this fire was
caused by Thatcherism and neoliberalism
and evil Tory rule in a way that just
didn't quite stack up didn't make sense
it didn't make sense for a number of
reasons firstly grant felt has been
there for ages and ages and ages and the
Tories have only been in power in this
country since 2010 prior to that that
Labour was in power for 13 years
so when you read Poli Toynbee who wrote
after Grenville in The Guardian Poli
Toby wrote this fire sums up the
politics of the last seven years
that's exactly how long the Tories have
been in power so apparently told us
nothing about when her favorite party
was in power I just found that utterly
unconvincing and also there were other
questions that they were just unwilling
to ask like you know why do people stand
their flats why didn't they leave their
flats and now through the inquiry we're
discovering that that's because the fire
service mistakenly in my view has a
stay-put policy where it tells people to
stay in their flats and it was telling
people to stay in their flats right up
till 2:45 in the morning which was two
and a half hours after the fire started
that was brushed over the question of
why the building was covered in cladding
was brushed over or it was simply
explained well all the rich people in
Kensington wanted the building to look
nice and they've demanded cladding not
true in fact the cladding is very much
related to the climate change act which
encourages public buildings particularly
residential buildings to have a heat to
have cladding which keeps heat inside so
people turn on their heaters less often
so there are so many different political
social historical questions that
influence this tragedy like are we
spinning out of control with climate
change policies is the fire service to
risk-averse and unwilling to encourage
people to take risks to save their lives
all these things and they completely
brushed over that they're coming out now
thanks to the London Review of Books
which published a an amazing 60 thousand
word essay on Granville last week which
I would encourage everyone to read
really
interesting and the inquiries they're
coming out there as well but what the
left did it just ignored all those
complexities all those difficult
questions the possibility that you know
left-wing officials also contributed to
the situation as as much as right when
people did they ignored all that and
just use this tragedy to demonize the
Tories and to big up Corbin Jeremy
Corbyn and the Labour Party thought it
was deeply sinister and very ugly and in
fact told us a very interesting story
about how distant that New Left had dis
than that Corbin astir left is from
ordinary working-class Londoners the
fact that it could exploit their
horrific situation so casually without
any consideration to what to whether it
was wise to use the tragedy to score
political points they see these people
in many ways almost as a stage upon
which they might make a performance of
their own virtue what is politics isn't
that what isn't no one politicians
always do they do yeah they do
no not all of them but politicians do
that but I but I think the left in
response to ground fell did it you know
in a really bad way and took it to
another level
and I think it did tell us something
very important about the opportunism of
the Corbin movement and their
willingness to use any tragic event to
dent the prestige of the Tories and
boost the standing of the Corbin
movement I just thought it was nasty
same thing good day very bad news on
9/11 right yes same thing oh yeah and
I'm sure the Tories get up to exactly
the same thing what Blair did it was a
number of instances Blair did it shortly
after the Bulger murder which you've
mentioned earlier he wasn't leader of
the Labour Party then he was yeah yeah
broken Britain broken Britain he created
all these phrases so he's the Blair eyes
weren't averse to using tragedies to
forward their agenda of course 9/11
being the perfect example where they use
that to not only very bad news but also
to venture into the Middle East in what
I consider to be a very foolish
oh yeah you don't need to tell me about
the horribleness of the Blair right side
kind of but my point is that with the
general nature of politics rather than a
particular thing about no I think it's
the nature of politics but I think there
was something specific about the
exploitation of grand foe which is that
it was very fast very thoughtless and I
do think it suggests I think it is bound
up with because of course what we have
now which we didn't have in Bulger or
2011 or in other instances we have the
whole social media climate where these
things can happen very quickly and you
have this process of virtue signaling
and this rush to demonstrate that you're
a good person so I was really shocked so
you so you're right in a way this is
politics as normal but I was also
shocked by the speed and brutality with
which people did it in response to this
file we didn't even know how many people
had died before they were making these
political statements and I think it's
bound up to a certain extent with the
social media the rush to the rush to
signal your virtue over what I would
consider the more civilized approach of
waiting in a reasoned way for more
information before you have your
analysis about what's gone wrong see
this is a point in which we can tell our
viewers and listeners that you don't use
Twitter see yes you're not familiar with
quite doesn't same extent but that is
the way
[Music]
on assignment they think social media is
actually contributed in many ways to the
death of nuanced journalists because you
know it's what journalism is now a lot
at the time is you want to boost your IT
you want to get hits on your art you
want to get clicks on your article and
get likes and sadly the reality with
Graham for anything is that it's
incredibly complex and it's going to
take years months to find out what
genuinely happened yeah and a knee-jerk
reaction is never going to be accurate
but if you create a knee-jerk response
which is simplistic it will tap into
people's emotional responses which means
that you will get the likes that hits
the clips yeah I think there's that
that's true I think there's this you
know we live in a very rash times where
people they kind of virtue signaling
before they think and there's that rush
to and I think social media plays a
large part in that where you are
constantly thinking well how can I use
this thing that's happened to make a
statement about myself and I think that
also is Springs from the politics of
identity and the politics of that very
narcissistic politics where you're
constantly making statements about your
life and your person and your views and
yourself rather than thinking more
rationally or more collectively or more
coolly and waiting a bit so yeah one of
the reasons I don't use Twitter is
because the thought of having a gadget
in my hand on which I could express my
thoughts to the world and the press of a
button horrifies me I have some really
bad thoughts they're not well thought
out some people would say they'd come
through in my articles by I hope I
managed to fill to the mouth we all have
thoughts that we wouldn't express or you
might only express them to your best
friend or you might express them moving
in a family situation we there's
traditionally been this barrier between
your private life and your public life
and in your private life you might be
more honest you might break down in
front of the loved ones home like life's
falling apart but you wouldn't do that
in public and and you needed that
private sphere in which you could cut
loose and be honest in order to then go
out into the public world there's a kind
of repaired confident individual but
that line has been erased and now people
have the breakdown in public and tweet
about it
you know they live tweet it and and they
say things on Twitter that previously
they might only have kept in the head or
said to a very good friend so I don't
like that direction society is going in
and anything I can do to create a
physical barrier between myself and that
situation I will do but when you think
about how the American president I mean
he literally got to power using that and
everything that you've talked about just
saying things off the top of his head
and tweeting them out he's actually
found an audience who are willing to
support him all the way I heard he
tweets on the toilet which yes just
terrifying it's like even I thought that
was terrifying first because it's the
president he shouldn't think doing that
but exactly because say the president's
allowed to use the time yeah you do that
but you should leave the phone outside
but it's like even the even the bathroom
is now a place from which you can speak
to that place where previously you've
just gone on your own and add your
whatever privately even then you're
still saying whatever people are saying
and I just think those boundaries
between private life and public life
existed for a reason and the key reason
I think they existed was because
everyone needs a sphere in which they
can just be themselves and relax and get
away from the kind of demands of public
life and the pressures of public life
and the pressures of work life and
everything else and just like chill out
and I think the more the line gets
erased the less we have that private
zone and everything is pushed out into
the public so Twitter I think I don't
think Twitter is the cause of this
culture but I think it has facilitated
it it's kind of it's the tech it's a
technology that has molded itself around
a culture that pretty much already
existed which is this culture where you
know when Stephen Fry is diagnosed with
cancer he makes a one-hour video YouTube
video about it now I know that a lot of
people like that and they appreciate it
but I find it strange and I think the
erasure of the boundary between how you
live and what you say in public is
probably a really bad thing for humans
it's very interesting we talk about
social media all the time and it's
interesting for us because we know now
given what's come out in recent months
the Facebook essentially they they have
people sitting there trying to make it
more addictive yes they literally have
people dedicated to making it more
addictive yeah and social media all the
studies pretty much show social media is
terrible for your mental health right
and we we both know that on the one hand
on the other hand we're making the show
right and we have to we have to reach
people right and social media is a great
way of doing it
can we just say from everybody here at
trigonometry social media is brilliant
videos and follow us we don't care just
stay with it
if there's a large cursing just like no
but that's that's I think the contrast
as well as like I think we focus on the
negative aspect yeah social media
rightly but there is also an element and
which is enabled communication like the
three of us would not be sitting in the
room in this room if it wasn't for media
I know I think social media is could
potentially being one of the greatest
breakthroughs in modern times because
the fact that you you know the Plus that
the downside is that people are saying
things they shouldn't be saying or
people now live their private lives in
public but as I said I don't think
social media made that happen I think
that had already been occurring social
media just made it easier I think that's
a cultural problem but on the other side
of it the fact that people can now
publish stuff at the click of a button
walking down the street is really good
because in history you know before the
invention of the printing press
no one could publish anything except
churches and monks who used to write
books and then publish them and that's
all there was then you have the
invention of the printing press which
caused this huge crisis among the church
because they suddenly thought oh crap
other people can publish books now as
well which they did and then that gives
rise to the Protestant Reformation and
the Renaissance in the Enlightenment
everything else Springs from the
explosion of ideas that the printing
press brought about and then the
internet revolution goes a stage further
which is that you don't even need to
have a publisher or an editor to publish
yourself you can literally set up a
website on your phone and usual thumb to
tell the world what you think that's
great so it's I I would put the internet
revolution on a par with the invention
of the printing press as in its
potential the downside of course is that
it tends to be used
in a quite narrow way I think and it is
it's as I say it's molded itself around
a culture of narcissism that I think had
been growing for a few decades anyway
Christopher lash wrote his classic but
the culture of narcissism in 1979 which
I still think is the best guide to the
problem of politics in the twenty twenty
eighth and twenty-first centuries so
that had been going for a while and then
the internet revolution lent itself to
that so that's the problem but the
potential of the Internet is
extraordinary which is the power of
people to express themselves without
needing to go through one of the
traditional gatekeepers whether it was a
censor or someone in officialdom or an
editor or publisher so that's great
and I think it is bringing people
together and it is a way for people to
express ideas but it's a double-edged
sword because on the one hand it's a
really good tool for communications but
on the other hand it has given rise to
twitch hunts and the shaming of people
for having the wrong opinion and these
kind of quite intolerant outbursts
against anyone who's considered to have
difficult point of view so at the moment
it's it's going through a very difficult
birth process and there are a lot of
problems with it but I would oppose any
effort whatsoever by government to
control it I would be completely opposed
to that and I'm very worried at the
moment about the way in which the
government in Britain in particular is
outsourcing its desire to control the
Internet to big companies like Facebook
and Twitter so it's constantly putting
pressure on them to take down certain
material or to prevent the expression of
certain ideas and I think that's a that
process of outsourced
state censorship to big corporations
it's something that should worry us and
those corporations incidentally as we
again are starting to find out Oh
brilliant please don't well yes do do do
do watch the video but they are not
politically neutral at all coming from
California that they're they they don't
reflect the full spectrum of opinion
they make sure the certain videos have
watched more than others they make sure
that certain people don't I mean no
James d'amour is a good example
yeah who was working with Google made
some what you might call factual but
conservative leaning points about men
and women and whatever and he was
dismissed and that tells you about the
culture that exists sir so there's no
way that company then has an equal
tolerance for all the different oh no we
are sleepwalking into a situation we're
very politicized massive companies are
getting to decide what you can can and
can't say in public because you know
this is the new public square
you know billions of people use Facebook
I don't know a billion or millions of
people use Twitter this is the forum in
which politicians speak in which certain
institutions make statements in which
ordinary people gather to have
conversations so if you are prevented
from being part of that or if you are
prevented from saying certain things in
there then you are being prevented from
expressing yourself in the public square
so that's a real problem and if these
california-based companies with all
their vast political prejudices which
tend to veer towards phony left that's
how they view the world if they are
preventing people from joining Twitter
or if they're banning people from
Twitter or if they are saying certain
videos and ideas can't be expressed they
are controlling public life and they are
controlling speech and that's worrying
and they now are enjoying almost the
monopoly on what isn't-isn't said in
public so that that's something that is
concerning I don't know the answer to it
but I think that something people should
be worried about so how would you
describe yourself politically Brendon
and do you ascribe to sort of these
Corbin eastern left-wing views which now
seems to be more more prevalent in the
political form
I hate Corbin ISM I'm not going to beat
around the bush I really do i I think
Corbin esters are really unattractive
movement I think gonna say unattractive
people some of them might be but that's
but they're it's a really unattractive
movement I think what they really
symbolize is the shift that we were
talking about earlier of the left from
class politics to identity politics from
an interest in economic growth to an
interest in environmental control and
from trusting people to run their lives
towards kind of censorious and
authoritarianism these are the big
shifts that have taken place on the left
the left used to believe in economic
growth for more jobs and more Industry
and wealth now it wants to save the
planet and stop the building of
factories the left used to believe in
universalism now believes in the
divisive poisonous politics of identity
woke identity politics at the left used
to believe in autonomy and independence
and now it wants to nanny-state every
single aspect of our lives from what we
eat to how we raise our children to what
we say in public so the left has
abandoned its core principles and I
think that's one of the big tragedies of
the times we find ourselves in and I
think the core bonused has expressed
that perfectly because what you have
here is a very middle class movement it
uses the language of Marxism and
radicalism and and you know old labor
and all this stuff but in fact it's a
very new form of left-wing politics
which is a narrow divisive liberal
anti-growth politics and that in my mind
is unrecognizable in comparison to what
the left used to be about so I think the
core Bannister's expressed that
incredibly well so I don't like them for
that reason I think in Britain at the
moment have this really incredibly
interesting situation where I think
there there are two revolts to political
revolts in Britain there's the real one
and there's the funny one the real one
is breaks it which is unquestionably a
revolt and you can tell us a revolt
because the entire political
establishment across Europe has gone
into utter meltdown in response to it
and literally cannot handle the fact
that these millions of stupid Britons
defied their instructions and voted
against the EU I think it's the best
thing to happen in British politics in
at least 50 years precisely because it
was so revolting and rebellious and an
expression of a desire for change so you
have this real revolt whichever one's
freaking out about then you have this
phony revolt which is the rise of these
middle-class Corvina stirs you go to
glass to bring a thing about Jeremy
Corbyn and who are constantly on Twitter
saying you know we're virtuous and
wonderful and we love poor people even
though they've never met one so you have
that phony revolt which the media's far
more interested in
because it's safe in fact they think
they're radical in red and they all go
and take selfies of themselves at Karl
Marx's gravestone in Highgate but it's
incredibly safe of all it's a quite posh
revolt it's it's very contained within
the narrow remix of identity politics
and work politics so I think that's the
most fascinating thing about Britain at
the moment you have this failure of all
which people love and can't get enough
of and then you have this real revolt
which people are terrified of and that
should tell you about which one of those
is more interesting I find it really
quite sad the thing with Corbin's voters
and that they seem so politically
unengaged almost but also they seem to
revere him as an idol and going back to
Venezuela he refuses to condemn the
Venezuelan government for what it's
doing to its people and then you try and
engage him with that and they just shut
it down they avoid the topic yeah I've
tried to engage with core Bernice's on
Facebook and I got told that I vote Tory
not that I'd see anything particularly
bad about votes and towards this your
political leaning you know that I
believe that you know by don't vote so
I've never voted Tory I'm old school
left left center left wink and also as
well that you know that somehow by
criticizing him you are all right that's
that's automatically the label that gets
slapped across your chest
just because you dare to have a
difference of opinion absolutely I think
the core bonus is a really good
expression of the new intolerant left
which is anyone whose point of view
differs to there's anyone who thinks
maybe left-wing politics is something
different to what you guys are doing or
anyone who says there's some problems
with Corbyn including who he speaks with
and who he hangs out with and and what
he thinks about the world anyone who
says that any of that is written off as
horrible and beyond the pale and a
fascist basically you're all right or a
fascist or a white supremacist if you
raised any of these questions incorrect
it's incredibly intolerant they have
this bristling instinctive intolerance
towards any person who doesn't fully
share their view of the world and I find
that really worrying I think it's it
really does speak to a new kind of
politics which is
very sectional and sectarian and
bubble-wrapped so the you're either in
this little sect or you're not and
that's not a good way to do politics
because if you're going to do politics
properly you really do need to be open
and open-minded and engaged and talking
to people you know if you look if you go
on YouTube and search for old political
debates between you know labor people
and toy people or there's a great video
debate between Martin Luther King and
Malcolm X right they had completely
different views of the world one was
super radical in a bit of a separatist
in a black nationalist and the other was
middle class decent civil rights
activist but they have this really
civilized debate even though they
completely disagree on fundamental
matters what we have now in Britain and
other places is completely uncivilized
debate even though in fact they actually
tend to agree on lots of things
it's what Freud refer to as the
narcissism of small differences and I
think it's often that the less that's at
stake in politics the more furious and
crazy and intemperate and intolerant the
discussion tends to become that's one of
the curious things I think about Britain
today which is that if you break it down
the Tories in the labor and labour
actually agree on many fundamental
things they both agree that breaks it's
a real problem has got to be ironed out
all diluted they're both into the
politics of identity as you can see from
the Tories gender recognition act and
call been never shutting up about
minority groups they both think
environmentalism is really important
they they agree on the fundamental
matters but they scream each other
fascists calm racist so I think actually
reveals the narcissism of small
differences actually reveals that
politics has become a very narrow
business so I always think the more
shrill and intolerant and shouty the
discussion becomes the more it tells us
about how there's sadly not much at
stake in politics now because if there
was if there were fundamental
disagreements about the future of
society you would actually need to have
a pretty open solid discussion about
that but there isn't well there you go
and listen Brendon one question we
always like to ask our guests before we
let them go
is is there one thing that you think no
one's talking about that we
should be talking about that's a good
question I think we need to talk more
about well it's something that I
referenced earlier I think we we need to
talk more about the fact that huge waves
of mankind still live in absolute
shocking dire poverty I know that sounds
like a bit of a happy crappy you know
something that none might say but I
think the reason I think that's
important is because I think we have
become so navel-gazing in the West and
so obsessed with their own problems
which actually aren't problems and we've
become so beholden to a narrow-minded
politics which says that economic growth
is a problem and the building of new
cities and factories is destructive that
we just forget that four billion of our
fellow human beings live in really
terrible situations so I'm one thing
that I'm very interested in is the way
in which the narrow mindedness the
narcissism the closed often us of 21st
century Western politics actually blinds
you to far bigger problems than we have
and blind you to the what were once
considered to be the great projects of
progressive politics which was to
industrialize the world and modernize
the world and encourage all sorts of
societies to embrace progress if you
read the communist manifesto which
everyone should read by Marx and Engels
it's fascinating little book because
even though is the birth of the
communist idea the first seven or eight
pages are devoted to praising capitalism
and to talking about the wonders of this
new capitalist society and the fact that
it has civilized all these once poor
communities it's it's internationalized
trade it's created these new vast cities
and factories and it just praises and
praises all the achievements of
capitalism and then of course goes on to
say but communism would be even better
and I think the left forgets that aspect
of it the left forgets the first seven
pages of the communist manifesto which
is this idea that it would be really
good if all of mankind enjoyed the same
kind of privileges and luxuries that we
do but we've become so obsessed with our
own navels that we've lost sight of that
and I think
it's really anti-human and quite tragic
well I think I think the viewers and
your particularly Francis will agree
with me when I say that has been
actually pregnant if someone wants to
follow you on twitter they cannot but if
they want to if they want to find you
online or find your work what's the best
way to access they can follow a spike on
Twitter so I edit spiked and they can
read me on Spike they can read me in the
spectator and they can follow spike
spike this on Twitter it's spiked online
they can follow me on Instagram if
they're young enough to use Instagram
that's about what's your Instagram
username burnt oak boy burnt dog boy
because I'm saying yeah okay so if they
want to see a picture of your abs go to
Instagram okay if you want to follow me
I'm on Twitter at failing human and I'm
at Constance in kissing thank you for
tuning in this week yeah I think that's
also follow us on at trigger pod on
Twitter and Instagram we're also on
Facebook obviously and please if you've
enjoyed it please give us a rating so a
review would be very nice five star
please and also as well um if you really
like it just recommend it to someone
that's it tell a friend thank you very
much we'll see you next week
[Music]